okay, I'm here to tell you that there is a
really important battle going on for the new
world order, but I'm not talking about the
shadowy totalitarian conspiracy theory stuff
that we often hear so much about. So I'm going
to set this up for you. If you've not heard
of these NW Oh, new world order conspiracies,
I actually congratulate you. You're probably
living a great life away from the toxicity
of this nonsense. But I'll explain to you
the way that these theories tend to go. Uh,
it's some version of the new world order is
a clandestine effort by powerful shadow we
players of the world to create a totalitarian
world government to rule over everybody.
Now that that's like the top line. There are
endless versions of this. Sometimes they involve
Freemasons. Uh, could be the Illuminati. Of
course. Sometimes it's the Jews that are involved.
Sometimes it's more of like a new age type
of thing. There is often a mass surveillance,
uh, sort of dystopian elements. Sometimes
it's framed more as an impending cool. There
are others who are more nuanced than they
say. Gradualism is going to be the way in
which this new world order is implemented.
It's not going to be all at once. It'll be
a little erosion of civil liberties here and
erosion of the sovereignty of countries a
little bit there. Uh, there are sort of population
control centric versions. Uh, sometimes aliens
and Ufos figure into it. There can be religious
connections that involve Bible prophecy or
the rapture or the apocalypse. You get the
idea, but the general gist of it is a conspiracy
for a shadowy, a world government to take
over in a totalitarian way.
Control of all people living on earth. Now,
all of that stuff is nonsense, but there actually
is a battle for what I think can accurately
be called the new world order in the sense
of a geopolitical realignment new world order
among the great powers. And right now this
is a battle being fought involving the United
States and China and Russia. Um, I encourage
you to read more international relations to
get more of a grasp on this topic and I suggest
to you, uh, that the, the, if, if you do that,
you are very quickly going to realize that
a lot of the stuff Trump is doing with Russia
and China is important for reasons that are
totally separate from the cartoonish media
stories. Okay. When we talk about Trump screwing
up trade and tariffs with China, or when we
talk about Trump seemingly sort of subservient,
subservient relationship to Vladimir Putin,
it's not about Republicans versus Democrats.
It's not about progressive versus conservative.
If you understand Geo politics and international
relations, you recognize that this is a key
moment because these relationships, us, China,
US, Russia, and China, Russia are inevitably
going to set the stage for the next significant
period of time in terms of how the sort of
major powers will relate to each other and
to the rest of the world. The rising circumstances
are that on one hand, Donald Trump is increasingly
hostile with China and he's making economic
blunders with China and Chinese economic policy.
On the other hand, Trump is too dumb to see
how well Putin is manipulating him. Uh, he's
doing it in a very particular way that is
useful in ways Trump can't even conceive of
to Russia, which we'll get to. And meanwhile,
and this is like the third part of the triangle,
Russia and China are building a relationship
that could be significantly negative for the
u s now, let me issue a sort of soft disclaimer.
You might hear me talking about this and say,
David, you know, we should just get along
with everybody. You're sounding like an economic
nationalist about the u s has to win. And
that's just the wrong approach. It's not about
that. Whether or not you're an economic nationalist
or a so called pro us person to use like a
really course term. There's a case to be made
that it's not just about what's good for American
power, but just about what's good for simple
everyday Americans who live in the United
States. And I happened to be one of those
people. So I'll give you some data points
about how this could start to shake out, which
wouldn't be good for just average Americans.
Look at Trump, China, trade relations, Trump
tariffs, China. We will now have years of
these terrorists at a minimum. Does China
suffer very little? They deal with other countries.
Other countries choose to deal more with China
than with American companies because it's
cheaper. This is bad for American businesses
as far as our citizens and companies are concerned.
The tariffs on China are paid by American
companies who have to pay more to buy stuff
from China, stuff that we need. Uh, we pay
more as American consumers for products that
involve Chinese raw materials or Chinese production.
Would we love to be doing business more with
our own companies and American made goods?
Sure, of course we would, but most of our
economy can't take it stagnant wages. People
are living paycheck to paycheck, so our tariffs
on China alienates us from them without really
hurting them, but they make more countries
turn to China instead of us. In terms of doing
business, that's bad for the United States.
Meanwhile, Trump thinks he's making nice with
Putin. It's so nice to get along, but Putin
is much smarter than Trump and he's using
Trump being enamored with them to Russia's
advantage while swooping in and rekindling
China, Russia relationships hugely.
Also in ways that aren't great for the United
States. An example, China giving Russian energy
companies, credits Russia, giving China access
to their energy deposits. China's army getting
access to Russian military technology. They're
doing joint training. They're coordinating
diplomatically. In the middle of that is North
Korea as a nation sort of caught in the middle
of the desires of Russia and China, and the
more Russia and China get along, the more
difficult it will be for the United States
to have leverage there. And meanwhile, as
I've mentioned before on climate change, one
of the foremost issues of our time, we have
the world just ignoring the United States
because Trump has said climate change is a
hoax created by the Chinese, and that's a
disaster. So let me be super clear. My analysis
is not from a neoliberal perspective. We need
a, I'm not saying we need to prop up the United
States at the expense of everybody else.
It's an analysis of a situation that's simply
too difficult and complex for Donald Trump
to handle, no matter what your view is of
what should be happening in each of these
relationships. The red alert is that we have
someone completely unqualified overseeing
this. Now we have a borderline criminal real
estate dude who's rich because his dad was
rich in charge when no matter what your politics
are, we should have someone involved in these
negotiations with knowledge and capacity at
what is an extraordinarily important time.
That's the real new world order battle that's
going on. It's not about free masons and Jews
in the Illuminati. Uh, and unfortunately we
have one of the worst possible people managing
it. Make sure you follow the David Pakman
show on Instagram. We'll have a poll question
related to the story at David Pakman show
on Instagram. And while you're there, follow
me as well. I'm at David Dot pat on Instagram,